et avec nous pour ce club bonjour ami
pintro merci beaucoup d'être notre
invité vous êtes sénateur les
républicains du cher président de la
mission d'information gestion durable de
l'eau l'urgence d'agir pour nos usages
nos territoires et notre environnement
et avec nous en visio à distance Marie
Mézières Fortin bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être là vous êtes hydrobiologiste et
on est ensemble parce que en cette
Journée mondiale de l'eau on va parler
de la sécheresse l'ONU alerte sur les
pénuries d'eau qui tendent à se
généraliser faisant peser un risque
imminent d'une crise mondiale de long on
va en parler dans ce club de la question
de la sécheresse qui n'épargne pas à
notre pays tourné toucher par une
sécheresse hivernale et on en parle
d'abord avec vous Steve Steve le
printemps est là depuis lundi mais la
sécheresse continue d'inquiéter oui la
Commission européenne qui tire la
sonnette d'alarme on va voir le
communiqué qu'elle a publié lundi en
raison d'un hiver exceptionnellement sec
et chaud l'humidité du sol et le débit
des rivières présentes des anomalies
déjà importantes notamment en France en
Espagne et dans le nord de l'Italie fin
de citation oui cet hiver a été
exceptionnellement sec dans l'Hexagone
le mois de février a été le quatrième
mois le plus sec en France depuis 1959
on a notamment assisté à une séquence
record de 32 jours sans pluie entre le
21 janvier et le 21 février c'est une
séquence qui a des conséquences ça rime
les nappes phréatiques de l'ensemble du
pays sont à des niveaux très inférieurs
au niveau habituel faut savoir que
pendant l'automne et l'hiver les sols se
rechargent or en raison de cette
sécheresse historique qu'ils ont
accumulé beaucoup de déficit ces
derniers mois aujourd'hui le niveau des
nappes reste déficitaire sur plus de 80%
du territoire il y a quelques semaines
le gouvernement attiré le bilan de cet
hiver inédit écoutez
on voit qu'on est partout en retard
par rapport à l'année dernière
on a donc moins de pluie on a des nappes
phréatiques qui sont moins hautes on a
eu moins d'enneigement donc on ne pourra
pas compter là-dessus pour l'été qui
arrive ce qui explique la très grande
vigilance dans laquelle nous nous
trouvons
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on est dans une
situation alarmante alors effectivement
depuis 2022 nous avons des hivers pas
suffisamment pluvieux pour recharger des
nappes et assez chaud et sec l'été et
c'est pas c'est pas nouveau enfin c'est
une situation difficile mais elle est
pas désespérée parce qu'on a connu des
périodes on a rencontré hier dans la
mission en cas de la mission un
hydrologue de lineray et qui nous disait
qu'en 1922 on a eu une période beaucoup
plus sec que celle-ci en 1947 en 1949
également donc vous voyez que finalement
l'histoire se renouvelle régulièrement
et cette situation elle n'est pas
désespérée mais à condition de pas
travailler par purinologie et peut de
libérer aussi les freins administratifs
parce qu'on a aussi cette difficulté de
la réglementation ou on n'arrive pas à
s'adapter si on veut s'adapter il faut
qu'on arrête de d'être dans par purée de
logique et de lever les freins pour
essayer de trouver des solutions il y en
a des solutions on pourrait vous en
parler on va revenir évidemment sur les
sur les solutions on va rester d'abord
sur le constat marie-mezzer Fortin
est-ce que la situation dans notre pays
aujourd'hui est alarmante est-ce qu'elle
est inédite
alors effectivement non elle est pas
inédite toutefois il faut pas comparer
avec ce qu'on a pu vivre en 1922 en 1940
etc puisqu'on était dans un autre
constat climatique aujourd'hui on peut
pas faire l'impasse sur les conséquences
du changement climatique et les
températures estivales que l'on va vivre
on savait déjà à la sortie de l'hiver
2022 que on aurait des difficultés au
cours de l'hiver 2023 il faut pas
répéter les mêmes erreurs on a plus d'un
an de déficit plus géométrique derrière
nous donc effectivement il y a des
solutions pour s'adapter mais aussi on
doit réfléchir à nos usages et à comment
freiner toute cette accélération du
grand cycle de l'eau est-ce que le dans
le pays est-ce que certaines régions
certains départements sont plus impactés
que d'autres est-ce que c'est des
départements sont dans des situations
critiques et d'autres finalement sont
dans une situation qui n'est pas du tout
inquiétante marie-mesert Fortin
alors tout d'abord tout dépend de ce que
l'on regarde pour ce qui est des milieux
aquatiques la situation elle est quand
même très mauvaise partout on a aussi
des régions pour lesquelles on a déjà
des difficultés d'approvisionnement en
eau potable dans le sens de dans le
centre de la France par exemple et un
bassin méditerranéen et notamment aussi
les Pyrénées-Orientales ou la
pluviométrie a été exceptionnellement
faible avec de vrais inquiétudes pour ce
qui va arriver pour cet été il y a une
inquiétude il y a une situation inégale
sur le territoire est-ce que c'est une
situation qui est rattrapable Rémy
points trop s'il pleut dans les
prochains jours où est-ce que d'ores et
déjà
il faut savoir que depuis 30 ans nous
n'avons plus de politique de gestion
quantitative de l'eau
et ça a commencé malheureusement en 1999
avec avec Madame voilée qui a stoppé
tous les grands projets de barrage pour
essayer de retenir l'eau de soutenir les
tiages de faire de l'hydroélectricité ça
a continué par le fait qu'elle a
supprimé repris les excédents des
agences de l'eau
qui aurait permis de faire des
investissements importants pour limiter
les fuites d'eau potable de canalisation
d'eau potable ou là on perd un milliard
de mètres cubes d'eau par an et un
milliard de mètres cubes de par an
désolé de vous le dire parce qu'on
oppose souvent l'eau potable et
l'irrigation mais ça permettrait
d'irriguer 500 000 hectares ça
permettrait de faire peut-être plus de
2000 réserves de substitution de de 500
000 mètres cubes alors c'est vrai qu'il
y a des opposants c'est le système mais
aujourd'hui le milliard de mètres cubes
d'eau perdus il est perdu qu'on me dise
pas que c'est au retour dans la nappe
moi je suis j'étais maire comme une
rurale je gérais l'eau sur ma commune on
a des kilomètres de de canalisation pour
servir très peu d'habitants et ce sont
des petites fuites un peu partout qui
finalement s'évapore par la et ne
retourne pas la nappe donc il y a un
gros travail à faire pour financer
ses calisations et avec la politique a
été menée voilà 30 ans où on a repris
les excédents ça a supprimé des moyens
pour les agences de l'eau parce qu'il
faut que l'eau paye l'eau et c'est ça la
politique qu'on aurait dû mener depuis
toujours on va parler de la question du
prix de l'eau évidemment c'est un débat
juste une dernière question sur le
constat Marie misère Fortin avec vous
est-ce que s'il y a des pluies
printanières ça peut rattraper cette
sécheresse hivernale pardon ou est-ce
que pour les sols le bénéfice des plus
printanières n'est pas du tout le même
que celui des pluies hivernales
alors il y aura un bénéfice des prix
printanières mais principalement pour le
stress hydrique des sols et des parties
vraiment de surface donc pour
l'agriculture notamment mais pour tout
ce qui est compartiment milieu aquatique
phréatique à l'heure actuelle on peut
considérer que c'est entre guillemets
fichu puisque la recharge elle se fait
vraiment en période hivernale au moment
où la végétation ne va pas venir pomper
cette eau et au moment où la comment
dire ou l'eau va pouvoir vraiment
s'infiltrer dans les nappes pour venir
recharger ses nappes donc aujourd'hui il
y a très peu de chances que les nappes
puissent à nouveau se remplir même si on
a un mois d'avril particulièrement plus
vieux et encore une fois compte tenu du
changement climatique on peut pas
réellement compter sur une augmentation
de la pluviométrie les scénarios ne vont
pas dans ce sens d'autre part je voulais
revenir sur la notion de barrage et de
stockage faire des barrages ne recréera
jamais une ressource on voit aujourd'hui
par exemple que le barrage de nos cinq
qui a été construit en 1983 et qui a une
capacité de 190 millions de mètres cubes
n'est pas rempli il est rempli qu'aux
alentours de 37 ou
Arlon 1900 habitants s'est fait une
frayeur la commune rurale au cœur du
puits de Dôme a subi une intense
sécheresse hivernale privant une
centaine de personnes d'eau potable au
plus fort de la crise il y a quelques
semaines les ravitaillements se
faisaient grâce à ce camion citerne
capable d'acheminer 80 à 100 mètres
cubes d'eau par jour des eaux prélevées
à 30 km de là c'est un camion de
transport de liquide alimentaire c'était
un camion laitier autrefois il contient
16000 litres depuis plus et orage ont
permis à la commune de retrouver un
débit d'eau normal mais pour parer à un
retour de la sécheresse la commune a
décidé d'acquérir le camion
définitivement moyennant des coins
importants pour la ville le coup
d'acquisition de ce camion là il est de
l'ordre de 45 000 euros quand vous
rajoutez si vous voulez l'achat du
camion la carte grise les assurances
donc le mètre cube d'eau transporter va
revenir cher et la situation reste
tendue autour parlant un arrêté
préfectoral restreint l'utilisation de
l'eau pour 14 communes et certaines ont
toujours besoin d'être approvisionnés
par des citernes ce jour-là dans le
village de beurrière un transporteur
achemine 30 mètres cubes prélevés en
Haute-Loire à l'heure actuelle tu fais
combien de rotation encore là sur 4 par
jour 4 rotations par jour
et ça depuis le mois d'octobre et ça
c'est nouveau pour vous c'était
en 2003 2003
ces solutions coûteuses pour les
collectivités pourrait bien perdurer si
la situation plus géométrique ne
s'améliorait pas durablement on voit
quand même une légère amélioration par
rapport
à la pluie qu'on a eu ces derniers jours
mais je pense que cette amélioration je
crains que ça soit qu'un feu de paille
s'il n'y a pas mieux de précipitations
on sera condamné je crois continuer dans
cette zone de moyenne montagne la
sécheresse hivernale est un phénomène
nouveau et pour beaucoup signe de
l'accélération du réchauffement
climatique à Arlon certains à l'image de
Jacques force plaide pour une meilleure
gestion des ressources en eau pour ces
10 000 volailles cet éleveur a décidé
d'utiliser un système d'abreuvoir
économe donc l'eau circule dans le tuyau
et c'est des petites billes qui
permettent d'économiser l'eau puisqu'il
y a une petite goutte d'eau qui se qui
au bout de la petite bille et le poussin
il voit cette goutte d'eau et il va là
il va la lever à peine avec son bec et
l'eau va descendre dans sa gorge
avec ce système Jacques utilise moitié
moins d'eau sur son exploitation
brancher directement sur le réseau d'eau
potable de la commune et ses économies
ne sont pas négligeables d'autant qu'il
doit aussi abreuver ses 600 brebis à
raison de 8 litres par bête et par jour
une gestion au cordeau qui répond aux
nouveaux défis climatique selon Jacques
on a vu un changement rapide c'est deux
trois dernières années donc est-ce que
c'est un changement radical du climat je
ne sais pas mais c'est sûr que
aujourd'hui on est dans un changement de
quelque chose mieux réguler la
consommation d'eau permet aussi dans
limiter le coût chaque année Jacques
débourses 2500 euros d'eau potable pour
l'ensemble de son élevage ici le mètre
cube coûte aujourd'hui un euro 40 mais
il pourrait flamber s'il est sécheresses
venaient à s'intensifier
mais on a vu aussi le maire de cette
commune est-ce que les élus locaux ils
vont devoir s'adapter face à ce
phénomène de sécheresse voir l'anticiper
bien sûr il faut s'adapter surtout
anticiper d'abord il y a le problème de
la sobriété bon je pense qu'on peut
faire aussi des économies d'eau potable
par des équipements de mousseur sur les
robinets qui permettent d'économiser 30
à 50% d'eau comme pour les chasses d'eau
où on peut économiser aussi beaucoup
d'eau mais après il y a aussi le
l'investissement pour pour les communes
et les syndicats d'eau parce que ce sont
souvent des syndicats d'eau qui gèrent
donc ces territoires et ça demande des
moyens considérables on voit bien que
aujourd'hui les élus ont peu de moyens
pour faire de l'interconnexion par
exemple je voyais tout à l'heure le
maire qui avait des problèmes
d'alimentation et il alimentait ses
habitants par des citernes bon après il
faut anticiper c'est vrai qu'il avait
peut-être fallu avec d'autres syndicats
voisins faire des interconnexions avec
des des zones où l'eau est plus AB
abondante en sous-sol et donc la terre
connexion est une solution mais aussi
après il y a les problèmes des fuites
que je vous disais tout à l'heure
d'eau de l'eau potable qui est consommé
un milliard d'eau perdu donc pour ça il
faut des moyens et les moyens on a on
les a perdu dans les agences de l'eau
d'abord avec Madame voilée et en ça
continue maintenant avec le fond mordant
ou on prélève 400 millions d'euros à 500
millions d'euros dans les agences de
l'eau est-ce que les moyens ne sont pas
aussi à trouver dans la question du prix
de l'eau est-ce qu'il faut aujourd'hui
augmenter le prix de l'eau pour dégager
des moyens que les élus pour période
où les contribuables déjà payent parfois
cher l'eau on est à 4 euros 30 ou 40 de
moyenne au niveau national il y a aussi
des limites il faut faire attention
à la mairie de Montpellier il y a un
tarif ou le prix de l'eau est très bas
pour les premiers mètres cubes qui sont
des mètres cubes de nécessité et oui il
augmente en fonction de la consommation
est-ce que ça c'est une solution ça peut
être une solution mais enfin bon il faut
aussi considérer que l'eau elle est
aussi
consommée par l'industrie
par il faut de l'eau aussi pour nos
centrales nucléaires et ça c'est c'est
vital pour notre énergie et puis par
l'agriculture aussi et les mètres cubes
les agriculteurs payent deux fois l'eau
puisque il la paye par l'énergie et les
investissements qu'ils font eux-mêmes
plus l'eau qu'il paye à l'agence de
bassin donc il faudra aussi faire
attention à ne pas non plus
augmenter trop le prix de l'eau parce
que c'est sur le plan de la
compétitivité ça posera un problème on
va faire réagir marie-mesers il y a
beaucoup de choses marie-maiza forte il
y a à la fois la question des élus
locaux et de l'adaptabilité des élus
locaux à cette question de la sécheresse
et la question les politiques publiques
de cette politique publique de l'eau
qu'au point intérim
ça devrait même être au-delà il faut
avoir un aspect il faut prendre beaucoup
de hauteur sur la question de l'eau et
se demander déjà pourquoi on a de moins
en moins d'eau sur nos territoires il
faut revenir aussi sur toute la
politique qui a été menée c'est-à-dire
que on a tout fait et on continue de
tout faire pour chasser l'eau de nos
territoires en hiver par un drainage
important et aussi en lien avec
l'artificialisation de nos sols donc la
première chose on devrait être de
permettre à l'eau de reconquérir les
soldes de pouvoir s'infiltrer et de
pouvoir retourner dans les nappes
phréatiques c'est à dire utiliser les
services qui nous sont rendus par la
nature ensuite la deuxième question elle
est celle de nos usages quelles sont les
usages les usages pardon qui doivent
être priorisés mettre tout le monde
autour de la table pour pouvoir avoir
pour avoir une gestion raisonnée de
l'eau ne pas penser qu'en termes d'eau
potable effectivement il y a aussi
l'industrie à l'ensemble des usagers et
les économies elles doivent se faire à
tous les niveaux on ne peut pas toujours
regarder que l'usager du village pour
économiser de l'eau il y a des réseaux
fuyard effectivement vous faites bien de
le dire il faut absolument investir pour
ne plus avoir ces pertes là mais on doit
aussi investir dans des technologies
d'économie d'eau aux échelles
industrielles aux échelles agricoles et
se poser la question de l'usage
utilise-t-on vraiment l'eau à bon
escient
pour la tarification je suis un petit
peu enfin en dehors de mon domaine de
compétence n'étant pas n'étant pas élu
mais aujourd'hui on a un tarif dégressif
pour certains usagers économiques plus
on consomme d'eau et moins ça coûte cher
ça c'est une réalité et elle a pas
vraiment de sens dans le contexte on va
parler des agriculteurs puisque vous en
parlez c'était dans également dans le
reportage de Jonathan et parmi les
solutions ont voulu par les agriculteurs
et qui font des bail à la question des
bassines pour en parler on va à Poitiers
où on retrouve Delphine Blanchard
bonjour Delphine merci beaucoup d'être
avec nous journaliste à La Nouvelle
République et c'est un week-end tendu
qui se prépare chez vous Delphine avec
une mobilisation des Antibes
bonjour à tous effectivement la
mobilisation contre le projet de bassine
aussi appelé réserve de substitution et
prévu le week-end prochain et ça annonce
d'ores et déjà mouvementée on se
souvient tous de sainte Soline ce
village dont personne n'avait jamais
entendu parler qui était sous le feu des
projecteurs qui est devenu le symbole de
la contestation depuis le rassemblement
du 29 octobre 2022 il pourrait
d'ailleurs être à nouveau l'un des deux
lieux de rassemblement du prochain
week-end Soline ou mosée sur le mignon
les lieux ne sont pas encore définis en
tout cas un arrêté préfectoral à
interdit comme la dernière fois le
rassemblement quel que soit son lieu de
rendez-vous on s'attend malgré tout à
être des dizaines de milliers de
personnes
averti déjà la Confédération paysanne et
la préfète des Deux-Sèvres elle argue de
son côté de ce qui s'est passé lors de
la dernière manifestation avec un bilan
officiel selon les autorités de l'État
de 61 gendarmes blessés dont 22
gravement autre décision qui met le feu
aux poudres et qui fait déjà parler de
ce week-end sous haute tension c'est le
contrôle judiciaire de Julien Legay
porte-parole du collectif bassine non
merci celui-ci n'a plus le droit de
paraître ni à Sainte Soline ni à Mauer
sur le mignon cette décision a été
motivées par le juge des libertés et de
la détention par la nature des faits
reprochés et le risque de renouvellement
d'infraction sur les sites des réserves
de substitution en tout cas vous le
voyez Oriane le sujet fait déjà parlé
dans les Deux-Sèvres mais comme sur tout
le territoire national dont il est
d'actualité et brûlant et donc tous les
regards seront portés vers Sainte Soline
ou Mosé sur le mignon ce week-end et il
y a l'inquiétude évidemment c'est à dire
dans vos pages Delphine l'inquiétude des
agriculteurs face à la ressource en eau
ouais parce que le sujet est complexe il
y a les écologistes d'un côté et les
agriculteurs de l'autre les prochaines
mesures de restriction d'eau font
craindre le pire aux agriculteurs et
notamment dans la Vienne ils ont lancé
une alerte au préfet alors que 30
projets de bassine sont en cours et dans
quelques jours il y a un vote très
important qui va avoir lieu c'est le
vote de l'étude achemique alors hmmux
pour hydrologie milieu
usage et climat par la commission locale
de l'eau et les irrigans sont au premier
plan forcément de cette étude comme
cette agriculteur qui nous explique dans
nos colonnes ce matin ici on a déjà
abandonné la production de tabac qui
équivalait pourtant à 12 salariés à
temps plein mais c'était trop gourmand
en nous on a donc fait l'effort mais
c'est désormais sa production de
semences qu'il craint de devoir
abandonner l'an dernier il a perdu 50%
de ces semences d'oignons faute
d'irrigation comme beaucoup il comprend
le problème de l'eau la crainte que
provoque les bassines
il y a déjà réduit en quelques années sa
consommation de
260 mètres cubes d'eau à 130 mètres
cubes d'eau et l'étude hachemuc lui
destine 18000 mètres cubes or lui lui en
faudrait à minima 45000 pour continuer
sa production à côté de lui dans nos
colonnes un producteur de lait avec ses
80 vaches et ses 200 hectares raconte il
me faut 50 mètres cubes 50 000 mètres
cubes d'eau j'en aurai 9000 selon
l'étude et encore ce producteur des
Chalons l'an passé j'ai perdu un tiers
de la récolte bon vous voyez le sujet
éminemment compliqué complexe avec un
volume d'eau en baisse de 73% programmé
sur le bassin du Clain ou les 30
bassines sont en projet ce qui implique
la perte de 450 emplois directs comme
conséquence tous les acteurs en sont
quotient pour leur personne la solution
tout le monde est autour de la table
pour en trouver on espère que la
solution vont vite arriver parce que le
problème de l'eau lui est d'ores et déjà
bel et bien présent merci beaucoup
merci Delphine la Une de La Nouvelle
République brebis tu es sur la piste du
loup c'est à la Une de votre journal je
vais vous faire réagir évidemment on
accueille Frédéric Dan et bonjour merci
[Musique]
beaucoup d'être avec nous journalistes
spécialiste des questions environnement
du coup on a un peu avancé dans le débat
Frédéric on en est à la question de
l'agriculture et de ces questions des
bassines est-ce que c'est une solution
pertinente pour vous bah ça dépend où ça
dépend pourquoi ça dépend comment c'est
décidé les grandes bassines telles que
sainte Soline oui ça avait un intérêt
pour une certaine production si le
climat ne changeait pas la l'étude
l'étude du BRGM n'avait pas en prison
compte l'évolution du climat et des
précipitations et ça allait aboutir
heureusement de bassines qui n'aurait
peut-être pas pu être rempli ce que je
veux dire par là c'est faire des
bassines oui mais ça doit être décidé
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle un
plan un ptgu implant territorial
d'études et de gestion de l'eau qui est
enfin voilà qu'on n'utilise pas
suffisamment autrement dit réunir autour
d'une table tous les usagers et discuter
de la hiérarchie de répartition des
usages de la gouvernance de ces usages
non seulement pour aujourd'hui et pour
demain et après-demain en tenant compte
de tous les paramètres climatiques donc
oui des bassines il en faudra même en
Occitanie surtout en Occitanie dans le
bassin d'ouro-garonne qui est le plus
menacé aujourd'hui et même peut-être
construire des nouveaux barrages pour
l'eau potable parce qu'on va en manquer
mais on oubliant jamais que l'eau doit
revenir toujours au milieu naturel bref
la position antibacine enfin pour ou
contre les bassines elle est
complètement con en France c'est un
débat maniché un stupide on doit
s'adapter au local moi c'est cache
l'eau c'est la vie et on a besoin d'eau
pour l'alimentation humaine mais on a
besoin d'eau aussi pour notre
souveraineté alimentaire pour
l'agriculture parce que imaginez que
demain on puisse plus produire même pas
de YouTube biologique parce qu'il faut
de l'eau aussi pour la culture
biologique pour produire des des
produits de qualité il faut de l'eau et
aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'on a affaire
aussi à des Jeudis très franchement des
le juste radicaux qui n'ont pas compris
que il fallait de l'eau pour produire
des céréales pour produire du maïs pour
produire des semences et ils préfèrent
peut-être qu'on importe tous ces
produits parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
déficitaire en ce moment en maïs en
sorgho en soja et demain il faudra
importer de des États-Unis d'Amérique du
Sud tous ces produits et sur le point
écologique c'est pire que tout donc il
faut qu'on essaie de d'avoir une une
politique vraiment réaliste pour
l'agriculture et faire en sorte qu'on
puisse produire ces semences chez nous
la proximité
il faut jamais oublier qu'un syndrome
c'est le syndrome de la bassine qui a
été montré par l'OCDE par l'UNESCO par
plein de rapports qui montrent que dès
lors qu'on a une bassine les
agriculteurs finalement font moins
d'efforts que s'il n'en avait pas parce
qu'ils savent qu'il y aura toujours de
l'eau et en Espagne c'est exactement ce
qui s'est passé ça contribuait à vider
le Guadalquivir de sa flotte c'est à
dire que la bassine est en plus remplie
parce le climat changé et bon on en
recréer notre et on en recréé une autre
et ainsi de suite mais derrière tout ça
les cultures n'ont pas été modifiées
donc les bassines oui mais pour produire
quoi si c'est pour produire
effectivement du maïs qui part à
l'exportation ça n'a aucun intérêt si
c'est pour produire de la nourriture
pour le bétail local oui si c'est pour
produire du maraîchage oui si c'est pour
produire une culture qui s'envole à
l'extérieur c'est comme si et c'est
l'inverse de l'importation d'aller
exporter de l'eau au détriment de la
population
du maïs on en a besoin on en apporte du
maïs on le prend il faut produire ce
qu'on produit pas en France qu'on
produit pas assez en France c'est ça la
priorité et je suis désolé mais
ça se décrète pas de changer de
production parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit
bien que on nous dit il faut faire du
sorgho à la place du maïs et faire du
sorgho ça produit trois fois moins de du
maïsage de l'eau de pluie
il faut qu'on arrive aussi à avoir à
répondre au marché si le marché nous dit
il faut que d'abord
pour pour nos éleveurs ils préfèrent du
soja et du maïs que du sorgho il faut
produire aussi ce qui on va faire réagir
marie-masia forte sur cette question des
bassines
oui alors je crois que Frédéric Denez a
vraiment bien résumé la question la
première chose à se poser c'est pourquoi
on veut stocker de l'eau et avec quel
objectif toujours garder en tête que la
ressource renouvelables elle est de
toute façon en train de diminuer le
commissariat général au développement
durable a produit des chiffres l'année
dernière on a perdu 14 % d'eau
disponibles depuis 1990 et puis ne pas
oublier que dans HMC il y a le M2 milieu
et que on ne peut pas et là c'est ce
plateau on ne peut pas parler que des
usages et que de l'agriculture il y a
aussi d'autres usagers mais il y a aussi
un milieu à préserver et tous les
services écosystémiques que nous rendent
les milieux pour nous et pour les
générations futures on peut décréter que
certaines cultures ne sont plus
souhaitables dans un territoire où la
disponibilité en eau ne permet plus à
ses cultures d'être possible je crois
que vous avez parlé du tabac c'est un
excellent exemple pourquoi maintenir du
tabac quand ça demande de l'eau et qu'en
plus aujourd'hui le tabac n'est plus
souhaitable
il y a deux meilleures des bassines il y
a les nappes
pour l'Europe au départ et puis après
ils ont mis tous les moyens mécanisation
et les engrais pour pouvoir le faire
mais aujourd'hui le problème de
l'agriculture c'est que il faut qu'on
leur donne les moyens de produire par
par les agences de l'eau qui peuvent
aussi les aider le goutte à goutte
l'aspersion
basse pression c'est c'est tous ces
moyens là qui mettent en œuvre et moi je
suis désolé aussi d'entendre certains
scientifiques qui nous disent il faut
gérer la pénurie mais la loi sur l'autre
2006 et la continuité écologique nous
amène dans le mur aussi parce que moi je
veux bien qu'on fasse de la continuité
écologique c'est nécessaire mais à un
moment donné la continuité écologique ça
veut dire que l'eau ne stagne plus pour
remplir les nappes elle file directement
à la mer et il faut un moment donné
arriver à faire des des zones humides
pour essayer de garder l'eau et qu'elle
s'infite dans le sol et avoir de la de
rechargement des nappes qu'on n'a jamais
étudié si suffisamment on peut recharger
des nappes de façon considérable la
meilleure le meilleur réserve c'est le
sous-sol vous le disiez monsieur on va
terminer sur les solutions et notamment
les solutions proposées par le
gouvernement et des abeilles borne qui
doit plaisanter un plan o dans les
prochains jours avec des objectifs de
réduit en témoin 30% en 2050 ça vous
paraît réaliste bah oui c'est réaliste
on est tous les outils le problème en
France
les Français sont prêts à la sobriété
sur l'eau oui alors ils y seront encore
plus près si l'eau était un peu plus
cher parce qu'on paye pas l'eau très
cher et tout ce qui est dans une société
de marché tout ce qui tout ce qui n'est
pas cher n'a pas de valeur après il y a
un vrai souci en France et la
gouvernance de l'eau qui est assez
exemplaire mais qui est totalement
bordélique il suffit de voir le rapport
de la Cour des comptes plus personne n'y
comprend rien et cette gouvernance doit
être adaptée à mesure que les conflits
sur l'eau va augmenter à mesure que
l'eau sera moins disponible au moment où
tout le monde en aura besoin il y a trop
d'administration il y a trop de
structures par exemple chez moi dans le
Nord entre le préfet du Nord et le
préfet du Pas-de-Calais il y a pas les
mêmes arrêtés sécheresse sur des mêmes
rivières voilà allez y comprendre
quelque chose donc il y a une réforme de
cette gouvernance de l'eau il faudra
plus d'argent pour l'eau
l'agence de pourquoi les agences de
l'eau doivent-elles financer l'ofb
l'office français pour les biodiversité
c'est un mystère pour moi pourquoi les
agences de l'eau ne peuvent pas dépenser
plus de milliards d'euros pour les
investissements
et je monte quand même votre livre
rencontre avec des écoloss remarquables
environnement avance au quotidien
merci beaucoup Frédéric un dernier mot
sur ce que vous attendez vous Rémi
pintroduction
un certain nombre de d'idées de mon
collègue qui vient de parler on a un
vrai problème de gouvernance de l'eau
dans notre pays une complexité
administrative sans nom il faut
absolument essayer de de supprimer un
certain nombre de règles administratives
complexes et de faire avancer nos
projets nos ptge par exemple avance
difficilement parce qu'il y a des
intérêts contradictoires entre les
idéologues les pragmatiques ceux qui
veulent aussi trouver des solutions
concrètes mais la France a besoin de
l'agriculture pour pour être nourri
de se débarrer mes points trop vous
restez avec nous on va regarder ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est trop maîtresse merci
Rémi point trop d'avoir été avec nous et
merci à marie-mezia Fortin qui était
avec nous en visio merci beaucoup pour
ce débat
[Musique]